hat den Mut mit uns zu sprechen vor der
Kamera ohne Kopftuch viele andere
lehnten ab aus Angst sie wolle aber nur
über ihre Kunst reden nicht über Politik
sie Male was sie fühle sagt Peter und
was sie fühlt es dann doch politisch
eine Frau hält schützend ihr Kind das
Kind ist ihr Land ist ihre
ganz unbewusst habe ich angefangen
gegenständlich zu malen und die Rolle
der Frau wurde dabei sehr bestimmen
auslöser waren der todmaße aminis und
der Beginn der Proteste vor einem Jahr
die Vorfälle von damals haben jeden
beeinflusst jeden der davon erfuhr der
hier im Land lebt jeden Iraner die die
Iranerin auch wenn die Reaktionen
unterschiedlich waren der Vorfall war
ein bitterer Verlust ich konnte eine
ganze Zeit danach nicht arbeiten das
Ausmaß dieser Katastrophe hat mich sehr
bewegt
der Vorfall sagt Bieter wakili und meint
den Tod von Massa Amini die junge Kurde
in stirbt am 16 September 2022 in einem
Krankenhaus entheeran drei Tage zuvor
war sie auf einer Polizeistation
zusammengebrochen nachdem sie von der
Sittenpolizei festgenommen worden war
weil sie ihr Kopftuch nicht richtig
getragen haben soll
es ist der Tropfen der das Fass zum
Überlaufen bringt Hunderttausende gehen
in den nächsten Monaten für mehr
Freiheit und gegen das Regime auf die
Straßen die Staatsmacht schlägt brutal
zurück
zehntausende werden festgenommen es gibt
Tote verletzte sieben Männer werden im
Zusammenhang mit dem Protesten
hingerichtet die Abschreckung wird
Anfang des Jahres kehrt wieder Ruhe ein
trotzdem gibt es weiter zivilen
Widerstand immer mehr Frauen weigern
sich das vorgeschriebene Kopftuch zu
tragen
die Gesellschaft hat sich verändert
wir und gegenseitig ich glaube es wird
nicht mehr so sein wie vor den
amini-protesten
[Musik]
die religiös konservativen Hardliner
allen voran Religionsführer Ali aber
weigern sich die kopftuch-regeln zu
lockern für sie ist es ein Symbol der
Macht
das Kopftuch abzunehmen ist aus
religiösen und aus politischen Gründen
verboten
nach und nach erhöht das Regime den
Druck Irans Parlament berät im August
darüber die bestehenden Kopftuch Gesetze
noch zu verschärfen die Strafen zu
erhöhen
ist immer so in allen Gesellschaften ich
bin davon überzeugt dass es aufgrund des
Ausmaßes der drohenden Strafen einen
ausreichenden Abschreckungseffekt geben
wird
abschrecken sollen auch diese Bilder der
Sänger mächtige wird im August
festgenommen kurz zuvor war sein
Musikvideo erschienen in dem er Frauen
aufruft das Kopftuch abzunehmen dieses
justizvideo soll zeigen das
Gesichtserkennungssoftware eingesetzt
wird um Frauen zu identifizieren und zu
bestrafen
kritische JournalistInnen wie nasilama
ruffyan werden inhaftiert die
Online-Zeitung entech ab wird Anfang
September geschlossen mehr als 100
Professoren verschiedener Universitäten
werden kurz vor dem Jahrestag der
Proteste entlassen oder in den Ruhestand
versetzt obwohl auch er unter
Beobachtung der Behörden steht
kritisiert der Soziologe Ahmad bucherei
offen die einschüchterungspolitik des
regis
sie nutzen alle Hebel um Druck auszuüben
damit am Todestag von Marcel Amini Angst
und Schrecken herrschen und die Leute
nicht auf die Straße gehen dabei
konzentrieren sich die Behörden auf das
Zentrum des gesellschaftlichen
Widerstands die Studenten und Akademiker
sie wollen damit auch andere Professoren
einschüchtern
lassen mögliche Konsequenzen nimmt er in
Kauf
es scheint dass das Ausmaß der
gesellschaftlichen Forderungen das
politische System überfordert das System
versteht die Forderungen nicht und kann
nicht darauf eingehen wegen dieser
Unfähigkeit sehen wir die Zukunft sehr
kritisch
der Graben zwischen Volk und Regierung
ist seit Beginn der Proteste größer
geworden weil die Staatsmacht mit harten
Strafen droht meiden viele den offenen
Konflikt aus Angst vor allem jetzt kurz
vor dem Jahrestag
auch die Rechtsanwältin und
Frauenrechtlerin schimagouche zieht ihr
Kopftuch vor unserem Interview wieder
auf denn sonst könnte ihr Berufsverbot
drohen es ist ein Kompromiss trotzdem so
sagt sie habe sich Irans Gesellschaft
seit aminist tot verändert ja unsere
Situation ist heute eine andere zum Teil
weil die Frauen einen Bewusstsein für
ihre eigenen Rechte entwickelt haben
eins davon ist das Recht auf den eigenen
Körper trotzdem ist es noch ein langer
Weg bis wir uns damit wohlfühlen und das
auch annehmen können damit meint sie
auch das Recht der Frauen selbst zu
bestimmen ob sie ein Kopftuch tragen
wollen oder nicht
ich reise viel auch aufs Land in den
Dörfern sehe ich dass die Mädchen dort
Kopftuch tragen aus welchem Grund auch
immer aber wenn ihre Väter mich sehen
ohne Kopftuch kritisieren sie mich nicht
mehr dafür die Akzeptanz ist gewachsen
Frauen Leben Freiheit das Motto der
Protestbewegung spricht auch aus den
jüngsten Bildern von Peter vakili wie in
diesem hier dass sie kurz nach Masse
aminis tot malte
und aus der Dunkelheit wie alle
iranischen Frauen aber durch die
folgenden Ereignisse hat sie auch Licht
gebracht obwohl der Vorfall sehr bitter
war kann er uns eine vielversprechende
Perspektive eröffnen
Iran habe sich verändert das sagen uns
alle mit denen wir in den vergangenen
Tagen Sprachen ein Zurück werde es nicht
mehr geben
[Musik]